of course he mocks you reading parenting books
because he doesn't want you to be educated
he wants you to just listen to him
and if he can make you feel stupid enough about doing it
maybe you'll stop
and maybe you'll rely on him for every bit of information
for everything
because those men who want to come into your life like a knight in shining armor
and take over
are really just trying to fucking manipulate and swindle
and take over your fucking life
that's why education is bad to them
they don't want you to be smart
they don't want you to read a book and know how you really supposed to do shit
so I'm happy you kept reading those parenting books